coup d'état à l'elysée
alain decaux j'allais dire naturellement
qui paraît aux éditions perrin ce livre
c'est une biographie ou une évocation de
l'empereur de celui qui va finir
empereur jusqu'au coup d'état
à vous lire on éprouve le sentiment
qu'au fond le seul moyen de sortir d'une
sorte de crise avortée dans ces années
là c'est précisément le coup d'état
quand on regarde en face la deuxième
république
on ne peut que constater que c'est un
échec parce qu'ils n'ont jamais su
trouver le sens de cette 2ème république
ya eu tout de suite début la république
une émeute énorme parce qu'on a privé
les
et de leur travail il ya une répression
républicaine qui a fait huit morts c'est
pas un bon début pour une république il
faut rappeler qu aux élections
présidentielles de 1848 louis napoléon
bonaparte l'emportent de manière
écrasante il est élu pour un mandat de
quatre ans non rééligible le grand
problème c'est qu'il est élu il a été
élu par le peuple et que les politiques
de la deuxième république ne l'ont
jamais admis il a demandé qu'on réviser
la constitution pour qu'il fasse un
deuxième mandat
l'assemblée a refusé elle l'a poussée
vers le coup d'état vous nous raconter
on peut dire minute par minute le coup
d'état du 2 décembre 1851 dont vous
dites qu'il a été extrêmement bien
préparé et il me semble qu'il ya deux
personnages essentiels d'abord persie ni
qui est relativement obscur et aussi
victor hugo victor hugo est présent
pratiquement tout le temps parce que
victor hugo c'est l'homme qui a fait
d'apple
pourtant son ennemi il l'a fait pourquoi
parce qu'il a passé sa vie à écrire sur
le premier empereur magnifique dont
notre cerveau rouges barrés dans votre
capitale
c'est bon c'est magnifique les français
ont lu victor-hugo pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils vont les ont votés pour louis n'a
pas loin cette majorité de 81 4% ce qui
est fou c'est parce que il avait lu
victor hugo et illégaux a préparé le
terrain de lwennas paul